turning to the worsening covet outbreak
in China many hospitals and funeral
homes say they are being overwhelmed
even as the government reports only a
handful of new Cova deaths Lucy Craft
reports from Tokyo where authorities are
now responding to the surge of cases in
China
Japan is sharply limiting the number of
flights to and from China where coveted
cases are exploding travelers from China
will also be required to provide a
negative test and if infected will have
to quarantine at a designated facility
for one week Japanese prime minister
kishida called the restrictions
temporary spurred by an information void
about the true state of the pandemic in
China which is lifting border
restrictions early next year a move
likely to trigger a flood of Chinese
Travelers abroad after nearly three
years of lockdowns under the country's
Draconian zero covid policy relief over
the end of lockdowns has been tempered
with a nation now in extreme distress
some estimates suggest more than half of
all Beijing residents are infected Dr
Howard Bernstein says his Beijing
hospital has run out of beds either that
the hospital is just overwhelmed from
top to bottom while China says covet had
has claimed only about 5 000 lives
scenes at funeral homes tell a Grimmer
story lines of coffins in an
unidentified building in northern China
seem endless
by at least one estimate China's
explosion of cases could kill one
million of its citizens by the end of
next year and threatens to unleash new
more dangerous mutations
for CBS mornings Lucy Craft Tokyo